por eso en lo que me escriben pobres son
los que precisan mucho porque se precisa
mucho es insaciable
yo soy sobrio no pobre vivir con poco
con lo imprescindible bleu porque para
tener más tiempo tiempo libre para poder
hacer que las cosas que me gustan la
libertad es hacer tener tiempo para
vivir entonces hay una filosofía de vida
e
[Música]
porque me teme si soy fruto de algo que
no tiene nombre
el error que no comete nunca el hombre
porque me teme
[Música]
si estoy hecha para estar arrepentida y
mi historia se ha quedado ya sin vida
porque me teme
si tú se lo me acuchillan por la espalda
y en mi culpa por haber estado sola
si tu ira me dispara en la cabeza
[Música]
porque me temen porque este mes
si mi libertad la tiene tu despojos y mi
cuerpo el recipiente de tu antojo
si mis hombres está detrás de tu figura
porque me teme
si el mundo busca cómo se rebela
y todo lo que hago es un pecador
pero si tú lo tienes todo controlado
porque me teme
y
porque me tenés
si me arrancas todo el aire que respiro
y me volaba dejando sin sonido si te
crees que yo sin ti no sobrevivir
[Música]
porque me tenéis
si el mundo a juzgar como cerrado
y todo lo que hago es un pecado
pero si tú lo tienes todo controlado
porque me tenés
a qué le teme
[Música]
[Aplausos]
primero os preguntaréis quién es este
chalado que empieza a revolcarse por el
suelo con la pintura aquí
pues estáis lo correcto
soy un chalado y no un sábado cualquiera
soy el más salado de los chalados si eso
se traduce una persona que trabaja día a
día para ser mejor y crecer y
desarrollarme artísticamente
yo soy palabra caccini
nació en argentina pero me crié en la
ciudad de los molinos y las navajas como
muchos sabéis entonces actualmente me
cuido trabajando en un espectáculo
acrobático en palma de mallorca
digo actualmente porque a lo largo de mi
carrera he tenido numerosos empleos y
numerosos aprendizajes con cada uno de
ellos
entonces he de decir que he estado en
numerosos países estado en túnez suiza
suecia argentina inglaterra francia y
hasta chinchilla estado es increíble
entonces qué quiere decir con esto soy
una persona impulsiva por naturaleza
pero he aprendido a largo de todo mi
recorrido que un poquito de disciplina
no viene nada mal
como diría mi gran amigo jesús honrubia
la acción puede con la intención y es
que es así queridos amigos
hoy vengo un poco a compartir con
vosotros cómo conseguí dedicarme a lo
que de verdad me apasiona vale y sobre
todo quiero compartir con vosotros el
hecho de que no comparto algunos de esos
temas que lamentablemente son normales
pero dicen que para ser un buen bailarín
tienes que tener una cierta los estudios
para ser un cierto artista tienes que
tener no sé cuánta información
y está seguro que la conocéis que es la
de para tener una vida estable y segura
tienes que tener un sueldo fijo
permitirme que dude de esto
madre mía se nota no aunque no queráis
esto cansa vale vamos a dejarnos de
rollos que levanten la mano los de aquí
cuántos de aquí os consideráis creativos
vengan os cortéis
vale ahora cuántos de aquí queréis ser
más creativos
vale vale vale y ahora levantamos la
mano aquel que me va a invitar una caña
de salida
eso es ahí tenéis una solución rápida
creativa para conseguir una visita
gratis
creatividad
la creatividad para mí es un sinónimo de
solucionar problemas pero dejando
nuestra esencia en el acto considero que
es sumamente importante que tengamos
nuestro propio estilo que tengamos
nuestra manera de hacer las cosas y
entenderme nos agobien todos somos
creativos en nuestro día a día por mucho
que me case por alguna causa que está
lleno de johnny créeme tío eres creativo
y si no mira el ejemplo cuando llegas a
casa de currar a la nevera coges lo
primero que pilla si lo metes no cuantos
hacéis eso
ahora qué pasa si os digo que tenemos
una
una cita en la que puede haber temas
qué pasa nos convertimos en el mismísimo
dalí de la cocina
tenemos pensado hasta el mínimo detalle
los pétalos el olor la puerta la canción
todo porque somos creativos cuando nos
interesa entonces chicos esto es como un
músculo se puede trabajar y se puede
mejorar sólo tenemos que mirarlo de otra
manera intenta ver la situación intenta
pensar de una manera diferente y que
pasará obtendremos un resultado
eso es vale vamos a seguir
voy a compartir con vosotros 5 tips que
a mí me han ayudado a ser más creativo y
cuando digo esto yo lo voy a enfocar
todo desde mi punto de vista que es la
danza vale
vais a ver el logo dt hasta completar ya
estoy un poco salado pero al final creo
que vamos a conectar entonces el rollo
es yo voy a dar voy a compartir mis
conocimientos y estoy seguro que si le
cambia jce lo que es el baile por
vuestra disciplina o van a servir de
mucho probarlas y luego me llamáis si me
decís que te han salido primero no
fuerces yo considero que no puedo forzar
es algo que tiene que ser natural para
mí tiene que ver mi estado de ánimo la
música la ropa que llevo todo
yo
le doy una gran gran importancia a lo
que son los rituales y qué quiere decir
con estos chicos básicamente en que cada
momento sin ritual
tú puedes poner música
o tú puedes poner la luz tenue ponerte
un incienso una vela y sentarte a
escuchar la música es ahí a donde quiero
que lleguemos aquí os conozcáis un
poquito más a cada uno
seguimos música como bien sabéis soy un
bailarín entonces yo no me cierro a
crear con solo un estilo de música todo
lo contrario me gusta empaparme de cosas
diferentes me gusta escuchar de todo
tipo de música no me cierro nada soy
agua somos agua entonces busquemos
vibrar de una manera diferente
esta es superimportante vuestra firma
soy un fiel representante de albacete o
sea yo soy de albacete yo represento yo
represento los miguelitos la feria el
templete no es sms yo represento lo que
es albacete en su esencia y por más que
viaje a numerosos sitios voy a seguir
siendo de aquí entonces no tenemos que
olvidar nuestra esencia y por qué digo
esto porque muchas veces se nos olvida y
yo en ocasiones con mis compañeros que
no estamos practicando y busca el crear
un nuevo movimiento pido ayuda externa y
digo ya qué te parece este movimiento y
si me dicen me recuerda un poco
lo eliminó llamarme radical
no seamos hipócritas aquí todos copiamos
pero muy pocos sabemos adaptar entonces
yo creo que tenemos que aprender a
copiar sin que nos descubran y adaptar
para que nos copien vale seguimos
transmite
creo que es súper importante
es básico que si aire está habiendo algo
pueda captar tu mensaje y voy a captar
lo que le quieres hacer llegar si
quieres hacerle llegar tristeza rabia
melancolía alegría que lo entienda que
habláis el mismo idioma por un momento
entonces creo que volvemos a lo mismo
del estilo a que sean fieles a nuestras
raíces y a vuestros principios en lo que
va a hacer que os diferencia es cuando
tú consigues transmitir a la gente te
vas a diferenciar del resto
entonces ya vas con un punto de ventaja
seguimos con el conocimiento
es algo que a mí me ha salvado el culo
en muchas ocasiones digamos muchas veces
como artista sabemos que hay periodos de
creación y hay bloqueos artísticos
también entonces en numerosas ocasiones
no nos obsesionamos con un movimiento y
no llegamos a terminarlo entonces creo
que tenemos que buscar una alternativa
con un parche provisional para cerrar
este ciclo y poder seguir creando para
que podamos seguir evolución de nuestro
arte porque digo esto porque muchas
veces nos eso ha pasado en algún ámbito
diferente pero nos obcecamos con un
resultado no lo tenemos lo tenemos y es
que perseguirlo por cuando lo consigáis
la perseverancia entra aquí entra este
juego y vais va a tener un valor añadido
este momento para vosotros
entonces el tener conocimiento de
diferentes disciplinas o diferentes
alternativas nos va a hacer poner un
parche provisional iba a ser una manera
de engañar a nuestro a nuestras malas
vibras y podéis seguir creando desde el
lado positivo
vale como ya sabéis aunque no lo parezca
vengo del bboying o breaking más
conocido comercialmente como breakdance
el breaking dawn entonces quiero aclarar
con vosotros un par de cosas bueno me
tiraría toda la tarde aquí hablando
sobre conceptos y cosas maravillosas que
me ha regalado el break y la cultura que
es perfecta para mí pero no os voy a
aburrir voy a daros sólo una rápida y lo
cortamos básicamente se trata en uno de
mis viajes compartió conmigo por wang es
un vivo y legendario y referente para mí
compartió conmigo una reflexión que me
parece súper interesante y me ha
perseguido a largo de mi vida que es la
de que para él el baile se diferencia en
tres etapas primera etapa eres un niño
pasa al parque a bailar y simplemente
vas tope de javea y le pasa te haces
unos molinitos y para casa toma la leche
etapa 2
llega un tío al barrio te mira le miras
hospitais te gana
by la lías entonces qué pasa con esto
cuando conoces tu primera derrota
perdemos un poco nuestros principios y
nos obsesionamos en mejorar para ganar a
este que nos ganó
quieto parao
pero es inevitable esto nos pasa siempre
tercera etapa una etapa ya más entrada
en madurez ya crecemos un poquito y nos
damos cuenta que tenemos que volver a la
etapa 1 a la de sentirnos niños a la de
sentirnos libres para poder seguir
creando tranquilamente lo he dicho antes
el volvería a repetir ahora porque
porque disfrutas cuando disfrutas
transmites cuando transmites te
diferencias
entonces bueno como bien sabéis a
nosotros los que bailamos break les
hacen llamar vivo y videos
en mi caso soy voy vale y rápidamente
meto un poquito aquí en terminología y
os digo la vez significa break que son
los 'breaks' los break son la parte más
cañera de la música que usaban los djs
en su tiempo
entonces lo interesante es lo que viene
después el voy
yo tengo 29 años no soy un abuelete pero
tampoco soy un boy pero este nombre nos
hace recordar día a día que tenemos que
ser niños y que tenemos que tener esa
ambición de niño esas ganas de crear
entonces esto es lo que me encanta de mi
cultura que siempre será un niño y ese
niño interior nunca se va a pagar mi
vida siempre la he visto así y me me me
regido así que quiere decir esto
prefiero pecar de tonto y no de listo me
encanta regalar amor soy soy una fuente
de amor entonces
cuanto más amor das la decisión cuanto
más amor das mejor estás entonces
regalemos amor a la gente y hagamos la
vida de las personas mucho más fáciles
que no nos cuesta nada
porque es importante esto aunque no lo
creáis tiene que ver con las etapas de
creación porque nunca sabes cómo va a
venir la creatividad ni quién te puede
aportar algo para que pueda seguir
desarrollándose como artista
entonces esos chicos ahora cuando
salgamos quiero que todo el mundo aquí
se empiece a dar abrazos y amor por
todos lados
y bueno con esto me ha despedido y
movimiento movimiento es básicamente mi
último proyecto de que me estoy
emprendiendo y es a ver si lo digo bien
el conocimiento
de uno mismo a través de la expresión
vale es un estilo de vida basado en el
minimalismo que es como me gusta
llamarlo en el que solo me centro en las
cosas importantes de la vida que son muy
poquitas pero tenemos que descubrirlas
para poder saborear las entonces
básicamente se forma de tres partes la
visual la musical y la corporal entonces
básicamente movimiento nació de la idea
de la de la idea de organizar mi cabeza
para compartir con las personas todo lo
bueno que me ha dado mi carrera
artística tanto en el break como
diferentes disciplinas entonces a qué
voy con esto no tengáis miedo a crear no
tengáis miedo a fusionar esto
simplemente nació como una cosa que era
para organizar mi cabeza y al final se
está convirtiendo uno de los proyectos
más bonitos de mi vida
básicamente me voy a despedir con esto
último y es que no quiero que tengáis
miedo a nada cuando me dijeron de venir
aquí aquí
vale
pero qué puede pasar pueden pasar dos
cosas chicos una es que nos salga bien
y otra es que aprendemos pero nunca
nunca nunca nos va a salir mal nunca
entonces animaros meteros en todos los
medicinales posibles
y darle con lo que tengáis en la cabeza
porque seguro que va a salir bien si te
gusta va a seguir bien como ya sabéis me
considero una persona creativa y creo
que yo desde muy pequeño sabía que mi
vida
iba a ir orientada al arte desde muy
chiquito lo sabía pero lamentablemente o
positivamente no lo sé
no podemos encasillar nos en un puesto
fijo o en un puesto de trabajo como
artista pero creo que el arte va de la
mano del emprendimiento entonces si no
encuentras ese puesto de trabajo crea te
lo y esa misma cara que has puesto en la
que se me quedó a mí cuando llegué a
esta conclusión brutal entonces chicos
no os cortéis ni un pelo hacer lo que te
dé la gana siempre con conocimiento y
con un por qué luchar por lo que queréis
que seguro que va a ir bien no os
olvidéis nunca nunca de ser únicos
gracias